my name is Brittany I went to Tufts
University I studied drama and
communications and I owe a hundred and
eighteen thousand dollars in student
loans it was just explained to us as
everybody has student loans and this is
just something you do to get ahead in
life taking loans out was just part of
what everyone had to do that they
weren't gonna affect my life that much I
really didn't understand the magnitude
of them until I graduated I graduated
college in 2009 so it was the height of
like the economic recession and the jobs
crisis everybody pretty much had to like
move back home and reassess what to do
then I started getting the phone calls
that say like hey so now that you're out
of school you're gonna have to start
paying back your student loans and your
minimum amount is astronomical
so my total do for this month seven
hundred and seven dollars and 74 cents
what will be applied to the principle
sixty four dollars and fifty four cents
so the principle is the total amount of
loan like actual money that I actually
took out what will be going to the
interest six hundred and forty three
dollars and twenty cents the interest is
not money that I actually borrowed it's
what they're making off of having lent
me the money in the first place so most
of this money is going towards interest
in total interest paid on my loan it's
forty eight thousand three hundred and
seventy nine dollars and seventy five
cents that's most of all the money paid
towards the loan has gone towards
interest so my principle is it going
down my debt isn't going down I'm
literally just paying the interest one
of the things I do when I am short on
money is that I go through my closet and
see if there's anything that I can sell
[Music]
I bought this dress for a tea I love it
not going on very many T's anymore so
all these empty hangers are from things
I've sold so get into the bare bones of
it all selling the clothes like it
doesn't cover my rent but it is extra
money towards my student loans I'm a
freelance production assistant I also
work at a dance studio as a receptionist
and I also work for a temp agency I only
took out money for loans to go towards
my tuition costs and I had a job for
paying for like books and like housing
portion I felt kind of in the middle of
a really hard situation with my family
having more money than being extremely
poor so we didn't qualify for a lot of
grant money but I have other siblings
and my family had responsibilities so
they didn't have enough money to help me
pay for college um was my car so this
was a car accident where this guy he
sighed hit me um one good thing about it
was that I got a check but I didn't use
it to fix my car I used it to pay my
student loan okay I hope I get some
decent money from my clothes it's really
hard to just feel like I can't really
afford rent I can't afford to eat out
it's like I can barely afford groceries
and it's all because of this student
loan debt and like I'm grateful that I
went to a great college and like I guess
they can't take away my education but
they've pretty much tried to take
everything else to have a drink of
alcohol you have to be 21 to take out a
hundred thousand dollars worth of debt
you can be 18 you can do that and I
definitely did not understand what I was
signing up for no one explained it to me
it's really scary to hear things like
even if you die your family or next of
kin will be responsible for paying these
loans if you're completely bankrupt you
are still responsible for paying these
loans every day I call Congress hi my
name is Brittany King and I'm a
constituent from Los Angeles and I was
calling to know what are you guys doing
about student loan reform
one of the only deductions I get on my
taxes is the interest I pay on my
student loans and with this bill that
would no longer be an option it's crazy
that I'm paying $48,000 in interest and
that would no longer be able to be
deductible for me and it feels like I'm
just down and they're just kicking me I
don't understand why you would make a
tax bill as to her people who are
literally just trying to a their student
loans and now you can't even deduct the
interest the crazy interest